now to Iowa where a search for survivors
is underway after the partial collapse
of an apartment building in the City of
Davenport it's not yet clear what
happened but a number of people have
been reported injured Meg Oliver has the
latest
it came down like it's frozen like a
bomb residents recalled the moment the
six-story apartment building known as
the Davenport personally collapsed I was
fixing uh something to eat I heard a big
bang and uh power went off fire
officials and police arrived to find
multiple floors of one side of the
building completely exposed
my medication and everything up there I
just came out there with myself
Davenport's mayor said at least seven
people were rescued by fire Crews and
more than a dozen others were escorted
to safety as they were exiting the
building several people remain
unaccounted for and rescue crews must
content with other challenges we're not
actually sure how stable the building is
even while we are on scene we did have
multiple secondary drops of debris
coming from that structure no cause of
the partial collapse has been found but
officials at the scene revealed that
earlier this week work had begun on the
complex and there are reports of bricks
falling from the building CBS has
reached out to the building's owner but
have not heard back so just currently
the building owner did have permits to
make exterior wall repairs that was
under direction of his hired engineer
The Tenors of this building are pretty
active they've called the city numerous
times with complaints that for different
things that were addressed by the city
inspectors and noticing orders were
issued to the building owner for repairs
for CBS mornings I'm Meg Oliver